with our state revealing job numbers for
the state we are now sitting at an
all-time high in employment our state
now has more than 1.4 million jobs which
is 3 000 higher than our previous peak
in 2020 but what does this look like for
those college grads getting jobs
christian has got the details that's
right well college students are
definitely taking advantage of these
work opportunities i spoke to one unlv
student today who says landing a job
after the pandemic was a true blessing
i lived in my family for a while i still
live with their mom and it was
really annoying to not have like any
money to do like anything
nineteen-year-old amani taylor can't
stop smiling underneath her face mask
about her guest service job at unlv
after being unemployed it was really
difficult i applied a bunch of places
got rejected i applied here like months
before i think like a month before i got
accepted and they just happened to text
me and ask if i still wanted the job but
taylor is not alone nevada department of
employment training and rehabilitation's
recent june report states nevada added 7
600 jobs in the past month boosting
employment to more than 90 thousand
since june of 2021. the labor market is
still pretty strong we've had an
experience over the last number of
months where we had
almost twice as many jobs out there as
there were people looking for jobs unlv
professor stephen miller says while the
job market is recovering there is also
restructuring that's happening and
positions to fill although we've now
returned to the prior peak in non-farm
employment
we're still about 35 000 jobs short of
the peak
in leisure and hospitality miller also
says those who quit during the great
resignation left behind opportunities he
says this is ideal for college students
like taylor i would use the handshake
app here keep trying to get the job i
got the job of a miracle i was literally
just applying everywhere and i didn't
have much on my resume
all right if you're looking for work job
recruiters say polish up your resume and
your interview skills referrals and
networking of course can help and
consider internships if possible